vamos a resolver este problema que se ve
bien interesante nos dicen que el
triángulo hace es isósceles entonces
hace es isósceles quiere decir que este
lado es igual a este lado de acá y
además en los triángulos isósceles
tenemos que los ángulos en la base son
iguales este ángulo es igual a este
ángulo de acá bueno vamos a ver qué
otras pistas nos dan además nos dicen
que ese eje es igual a 24 eje es igual a
nos dicen que bh es igual a df le voy a
poner dos marquitas aquí
vh es igual al df nos dicen que gf es
igual a 12 estoy acá es igual a 12
y finalmente finalmente nos dicen que f
es igual a 6 efe estar acá es igual a 6
muy bien y con estas pistas y estos
ángulos rectos de aquí ángulos de 90
grados
nos piden determinar el área del
pentágono cbhf de cbhf de déjame
sombrear la es esta área de acá entonces
tenemos que determinar el valor de esa
área vale esta de aquí
bueno pues un buen plan sería determinar
el área de acb y luego restarle el área
de estos dos pequeños triángulos sin
embargo todavía estamos muy lejos de
poder ejecutar nuestro plan porque así
quisiéramos encontrar el área de a s
necesitaríamos su altura que ya la
tenemos pero también su base que todavía
no la tenemos sólo tenemos un cacho y
bueno de manera similar cuando cuando
quisiéramos encontrar estas áreas estas
áreas de estos triángulos pequeños vamos
a necesitar su base y su altura aquí nos
falta la altura y aquí nos faltan las
dos bueno entonces vamos a ir poco a
poco encontrando las longitudes que nos
faltan y seguramente puedes imaginarte
que esto va a tener que ver con algunos
argumentos de semejanza porque es el
tema que hemos estado platicando y si en
efecto aquí hay varios triángulos
semejantes por ejemplo el triángulo cg
es semejante al triángulo de f
vamos a mostrar eso observa que este
ángulo de aquí es de 90 vale pero este
ángulo de acá también es de 90 porque
aquí tenemos un ángulo de 90 entonces
los triángulos cg y df comparten este
ángulo de 90 pero además también
comparten este ángulo en que tenemos que
ese eje es igual a d e f y entonces los
triángulos eje y df son semejantes por
el criterio por el criterio ángulo
ángulo déjalo escribo por acá entonces
el triángulo cg en ese eje
es semejante al triángulo de f es
importante tener los lados bien entonces
vamos a ver d efe
efe tenemos el ángulo recto en que
tenemos el ángulo recto y aquí tenemos
con el ok entonces esto de aquí es por
el criterio ángulo ángulo y ahora esta
semejanza nos va a permitir usar las
razones para determinar esta longitud
vamos a hacerlo
cómo le hacemos pues ve este lado es
correspondiente con este entonces si
ponemos la razón de efe entre cg que
mide 24 24 eso debe ser igual a la razón
entre este lado con el correspondiente
que sería 6
entre gm y gm no vale 12 ojo vale 18
porque es toda esta longitud entonces
sería igual a 6 entre 18 y de aquí
podemos encontrar df 6 entre 18 es un
tercio y podemos multiplicar por 24 de
ambos lados por 24 por 24 este 24 se
cancela con ese y nos queda que de efe
es igual a 24 entre 3 o sea a 8 va
entonces ya tenemos la longitud desde
efe déjame ponerlo aquí en la figura
aquí le voy a poner que es igual a 8 y b
nos dicen que bh es igual a df entonces
b h también es igual a 8
bueno vamos a hacer algunos otros
argumentos más de semejanza vamos con
este triangulito de aquí con este
triangulito de acá observa que una vez
más este ángulo el vih
es recto y el b a h es igual al d
efe entonces estos dos triángulos de
aquí una vez más son semejantes por
criterio ángulo ángulo pero observa
además tenemos este esta longitud de
ocho aquí y acá entonces los triángulos
no sólo son semejantes sino que son
congruentes vale tenemos este ángulo
igual a éste y el lado en medio entonces
por criterio ángulo lado ángulo los dos
triángulos son congruentes lo voy a
poner por acá tenemos que el triángulo
el triángulo de h a b
h es congruente al triángulo de f es
importante ver que el orden sea correcto
de f
efe y si lo es verdad en h y ene efe
tenemos los ángulos rectos en a n
tenemos los ángulos naranjas muy bien
entonces estos dos triángulos son
congruentes y por lo tanto sus lados
correspondientes son iguales no sólo
proporcionales sino iguales como efe es
igual a 6 entonces a h también va a ser
igual a 6 vale esto de aquí también es 6
muy bien creo que ya ves más o menos a
dónde va todo esto verdad al parecer
esto también va a medir 12 y con eso
vamos a tener la base pero bueno vamos a
demostrarlo para estar totalmente
seguros de ello y para eso vamos a
utilizar una semejanza más entre el
triángulo b
y el cg entonces ve aquí tenemos un
ángulo recto
aquí tenemos este ángulo recto vih es
congruente acg a una vez más el ángulo
en aló comparten ambos triángulos
por criterios ángulo ángulo tenemos que
el triángulo bh vih es semejante al
triángulo cg
y entonces las proporciones
correspondientes deben de ser las mismas
es decir si tomamos a h / a g no voy a
poner por aquí a hs 6 / g eso debe de
ser igual a la otra proporción la de
este lado con este lado es igual a 8
entre 24 es igual a 8 entre 24 8 entre
24 es igual a un tercio y por lo tanto
pasando el ag multiplicando hacia acá y
el 3 pasando multiplicando hacia acá
tenemos que aje ag es igual a 18 y eso
está súper padre porque nos da la
longitud de hasta g pero como ya tenemos
la de h mide 6 entonces la de hg debe de
medir 23 18
6 vale entonces estoy aquí es 12 y listo
con esto ya tenemos todas las longitudes
que nos interesan ya tenemos la base la
altura y la base y la altura de estos
triángulos de al lado entonces vamos a
empezar calculando el área del triángulo
y entonces el área el área de hacer y de
hacer es igual a un medio multiplicado
por la base 612 es 18 con otros 18 son
36 un medio por 36 x la altura por 24 y
esto de aquí es igual a pues 36 entre 12
18 18 por 24 vamos a hacer la operación
aquí entonces vamos a poner 24 por 18
esto nos queda 4 por 832 llevamos 38 con
2 son 16 y 3 son 19 y luego este 10 del
18 por el 24 más de 240 sumamos 20 es 29
y 43 y llevamos un a 432 entonces el
área del triángulo hace es igual a 432
pero todavía no hemos terminado porque
ahora debemos restar estas áreas
laterales y esta de aquí
y esta de acá y son dos áreas iguales
verdad entonces basta con encontrar una
de ellas entonces vamos a determinar el
área del triángulo a b h
otra vez usamos la fórmula de área para
un triángulo tenemos un medio de 6 x 8
un medio de 48 que es igual a 24 es
igual a 24 y entonces a esta área
tenemos que restarle dos veces 24
tenemos que restarle 48 entonces ya aquí
viene el redoble de tambores vale
entonces tenemos que el área del
pentágono que nos interesa el c b h
efe de es igual a 432 menos 48 y aquí ya
nada más hay que hacer la resta entonces
primero tenemos que pues déjame restar
primero 32 y luego 16
eso sería restar 48 si restamos 32 nos
queda en 400 si restamos 16 nos queda
384 384
al de 384 entonces si hice todo bien 384
es el área del pentágono que nos
interesa nada más dejar checo 384 48 4 y
82 llevamos una 4 y 2 82 y una que
llevamos 3 y 1 ok 432 y si entonces el
área del pentágono es igual a 384